well ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
third of the series systems and lecture
series congratulations for getting
through the snow and ice and dripping
conditions we might have one or two
people slipping in late of course
because of this but they were thank you
for coming and being on time and thank
you especially if you've been to all
three of these lectures by William
Parker distinguished servant in the
country of foreign service commentator
foreign service practitioner also of
many words before but by oh and the
announcement of the lectures themselves
we're going to have the same format as
with previous two lectures ladies and
gentlemen a talk about an hour and then
time for for Q&A if I see it a lot of
times I find that we may keep it we make
a five or ten minutes longer than we
generally plan but what do you just join
me in welcoming what in for two
[Applause]
thank you very much this is very
complimentary given the weather today he
showed up I'm so delighted to be back
again in my previous two talks some of
you will remember I discussed the impact
of colonialism and militarism on
American society and what the Founding
Fathers did to try to make American
Liberty more secure and the changes the
successors made now in this final
discussion I turn to what has been tried
to enhance the chances of our achieving
what I call affordable world security
and what has diminished our chances of
achieving it you don't need me to
recount the flow of violence in the
world that pours over us every day from
the media bombings assassinations
renditions torture or war have become
the saga we live with instead what I'm
going to do today is to discuss and
probe into how the world of which we
live evolved at the end of the Second
World War
how our government and its advisors
tried to understand and cope with what
they perceive to be the threats to our
security this is both a large and
diffuse topic and I will be able to deal
with only a few aspects of it and even
with those I'll have to skip much so
I'll try to be brief but I warn you I
probably will fail I begin with two
views why they separated in time on
where we are today speaking at the
University of Chicago in 1950 the grand
strategist of the Cold War George Kennan
said that the central puzzle that
confronts Americans was the decline of
American security a half century ago he
said people in this country had a sense
of security visibly the world
environment such as I suppose no people
have ever had since the days of the
Roman Empire today that pattern is
almost reversed we have before us a
situation which I'm Frank to admit seems
to me dangerous and
problematical in the extreme how did the
country so secure become a country so
insecure that was 68 years ago what has
happened since have our policies our
efforts our vast expenditure of talent
and money resulted in the security we
tried to achieve one answer was given
last September by the official who's
essentially responsible for our major
European of Foreign Affairs area the
chief of NATO the world he said is at
its most dangerous point in a generation
you will have also seen that The
Bulletin of the Atomic Scientists had
just moved us half a minute closer to
midnight
in fact our country has been secure at
least in the sense that we were not
engaged in hostilities somewhere for
only about twenty years since the 1787
Constitutional Convention that I
discussed the other day and since the
Vietnam War we've been engaged in almost
non-stop conflicts throughout most of
the world what the editors of the New
York Times called America's Forever Wars
now have us engaged in military
operations in at least a hundred and
seventy two countries and territories
more than a quarter of a million
American servicemen and women backed up
by nearly that many mercenaries and
special agents have been carrying out
the whole gambled of overt military and
covert espionage activities in my book
crusade in Jihad I dealt with some of
the reasons behind the dangers we face I
focused there on overseas events and
particularly on the blowback of people's
throughout the world against imperialism
colonialism and foreign intervention
today I want to deal primarily with what
America has done and its attempt to
create security for itself I will avoid
as much as possible assessing blame or
giving credit but rather will try to
analyze actions in terms of their
success or failure to put our actions in
perspective
I'm sorry I begin with what other
nations have done that set the content
the context in which we've operated and
what we've learned or particularly from
Great Britain that have so influenced
our own strategies and tactics is there
really anything we can think of as
security that is within the general aims
of our society is security possible
Dwight Eisenhower doubted it
he said if you want total security go to
prison there you were fed clothed given
medical care and so on the only thing
lacking is freedom I believe you'll
agree with me that that degree of
security is not affordable indeed trying
to achieve it has costs that sometimes
make the medicine worse than the
sickness but security has been the prime
objective of societies from the earliest
times everywhere people built defensive
barriers already in the little town of
Jericho about 7,000 BC as we all learned
in the beautiful afro-american spiritual
the walls come tumbling down but just
the task of building them virtually
destroyed the town it has been
calculated that about every adult male
must have spent a quarter of his adult
life
laboring by hand to carry quarry and
places much rock on earth as we fill a
large trailer truck today workers hardly
had time to hurt animals or raise crops
even that huge expenditure of human
muscle Wollaston save Jerico
we know the inhabitants were killed
carried off or ran away and were
replaced by invaders time after time so
their successors had to build or rebuild
Jericho's walls at least 20 times but
almost everywhere into all times walls
continued to be built the Egyptian
hieroglyph for town was wall and the
Chinese ideograph for city charing rises
from the characterful wall the Great
Wall of China the eye and its smaller
cousin Hadrian's Wall
for work of generations medieval Europe
was made up of wall towns the costs of
building and Manning its defenses
literally blood the beautiful little
city of Siena to death we're all at it
again in our time the Maginot Line the
Italian barrier along the Libyan
Egyptian frontier the French barrier
they built during the Algerian war along
the Algerian Tunisian frontier the
Berlin wall the Israeli wall against the
Palestinians and today mr. Trump is
trying to copy them with a Mexican
border common to all these efforts is
that they were you ruinously expensive
and that they never worked so the
stronger larger and better organized
societies often said about to destroy
their enemies in their own homelands
from the time of the ancient Assyrians
the powerful carried ward of weaker
nations much as the Americans did the
Red Indians as I described in my first
talk the boys did to the bun to the
Chinese did to the Central Asian
Hungarians and and no amount of military
action brought more than a temporary
security more of the creation and the
use of armies like wall building came at
a ruinous cost whole societies were
transformed corrupted or ruined by
militarization in medieval Italy for
warfare was endemic a single campaign
might cost the city-state ten times its
annual revenue so it was that we owe to
Florence two of the actions of
government that control so much of our
lives today
Florence created the first European tax
the Qatar so and when they that did not
suffice they carried out the first
system of public debt the Monti communy
or mountain of debt today we have
enormous Li amplified both of these our
wars cannot be paid for by taxation and
we will leave the bill for to our
grandchildren and perhaps even to their
grandchildren even more detrimental than
the monetary cost is the militarization
of society as I pointed out my previous
talk our founder and fathers new
the that the pursuit of security through
militarization transforms subverts or
curtails essential liberties and so
weakens the civic institutions and
practices it was proposed to suggest to
protect indeed as Henry L Stimson in
whose name we meet today presently wrote
back in 1932 unless some move is made to
prevent war modern civilization might be
doomed his answer was a peace convention
the Briand kellogg packed for the
renunciation of war it was signed by
most independent nations but it too did
not work it was not long before Germany
and Italy bombed and destroyed
Republican Spain Italy conquered
Ethiopia and Japan pillage and rape much
of China and they bought the evils of
war traverser II the whole world
including of course America but Hope
Springs the turul treaties are still
being tried biological weapons were
legally banned about a half a century
ago and chemical weapons were banned a
few years later but these horrible
weapons continue to be manufactured
stored and occasionally used and July
last year 122 nations signed a tree
calling for the prohibition of nuclear
weapons but of course the ones that
signed were the ones that didn't have
weapons the decision did not make war
but it accentuated what I call the
apprehension of danger that shapes our
lives today
of course apprehension danger of itself
leads to war but even when it does not
it weakens the most precious and most
fragile of our cultural attributes our
sense of civilized life this is perhaps
most evident and the use of torture and
other inhuman activities that not only
impact on the victims but also pervert
those that employ them I would say as an
aside one of the things that frightens
me very much is to think that many of
the people we've trained for example to
carry out midnight raids in which people
are killed in their beds
without any immediate concern for them
bringing those people back to our
society may turn out to be one of the
most dangerous things we've ever done so
a few men a few men have tried to dig
deeper into the question of why we all
not just Americans are a warring people
and his open letter of nineteen of July
30 1932 which is often referred to as
the SA y war Albert Einstein asked is
there any way of delivering mankind from
the Menace of war which has come to mean
a matter of life and death for
civilization as we knew it despite all
the zeal displayed he said every attempt
at solution has ended in the mandible
breakdown this must be he concluded
because man has within himself such
hatred and destruction what can be done
about this Einstein decided the best
person to address this question to was
Sigmund Freud but Freud offered Einstein
neither solution nor solace he believed
that human nature was incorrigible he
thought that the only hope was to wrap
monic mankind and what he called a
Supreme Court of Judicature with
adequate executive force because any
effort to replace brute force by the
force of an ideal he said under present
conditions is doomed to fail there is no
likelihood of our being able to suppress
humanity's aggressive tendencies so what
is the record of humanity's aggressive
tendencies in our time forgive me for
indulging in some detail it does no good
to break out the current litany of
events where deadly regaled with them
I'm also reacting I have to say against
the attitude I encountered during my
brief time in government service never
ask what caused a given problem just
deal with it and see what it can be done
at that time in Texas and my youth that
people used to use the expression ready
you'd aim I think it is important in
trying to see what prevents us from
feeling secure to know how Americans got
involved in with with the issue of
security and what we're trying to do to
achieve it there is no a great place to
begin discussion of the till most of the
last century but it seems to me that the
character and dimensions of the
challenge we face right now are marked
by strategic doctrines and tactical
actions we can trace down and perhaps
rather crudely summarized under the
totem animals that we have in the world
the law and the bear and the eagle the
British lion had grabbed large chunks of
the Vogel Empire and was feeding itself
and financing what we call the
Industrial Revolution from the rich
Indian subcontinent without the Indian
empire King George the 3rd 3rd that
England would be as he called it a
toothless little beast living off the
scraps but with India it became a lord
of the world so the lion roared and
flailed a way to acquire not only India
but also its neighborhood and to keep
everyone else out the most important
everyone else was the Russian bear
starting with Ivan the Terrible Russian
Czars
plunge down the long dominant vodka and
they too wanted a piece of India Peter
the Great God as far as the Caspian Sea
and his successors who their armies into
the Ottoman Empire and attempts to break
out of the Black Sea into the warm
Mediterranean the epic and romanticized
battles of the line of the bear the
great game in the towering mountains of
Afghanistan and the charge of the Light
Brigade in the Crimea were the nursery
rhymes and effective woods in Churchill
all his life Churchill was obsessed with
blocking the russian route to british
india to him that meant keeping the
Ottoman Empire alive and enabling it to
hold to the choke point as I was try to
just call it of the Turkish straight
with a cork in the bottle opening at
Istanbul the right
would be contained to the Black Sea
British strategy work but the Turks
eventually overplayed their part and the
First World War they close the Straits
to both the Russians and the British and
starve Russia into the 1917 revolution
war and revolution swept away the 19th
century in just a few years both the
Ottoman Empire and the Russian Empire
collapsed and British India began the
political evolution that would lead a
quarter of a century later to its
independence the world changed but
churchill ever the imperialists kept to
his strategy if india would no longer be
but the British Empire the Churchill's
certainly tried his best to prevent the
coming of independence the neighborhood
became a vital British interest the
India's contribution of the Empire was
taken up by the oil fields of the Middle
East particularly in Iran without Middle
Eastern oil got cheap on concessionary
terms of imperialism Churchill feared
that England would starve so the
overriding goal was to find a neat
checkpoint to keep out the Russians
since Turkey was no longer available he
decided the best barrier was Greece he
determined that Greece would be
Britain's notional wall Churchill's
strategy was a hold over the 19th
century then the powerful countries
treated the weaker countries like
lifeless pieces to be moved around on
the playing board other great powers
Churchill and many others followed the
South African leader General Yan Smuts
in thinking of little countries as
dominoes neither in Greece nor elsewhere
to Churchill see that in the struggling
for freedom societies had become nations
with their own aspirations to Churchill
Greece was still just a domino he had
little interest in virtually no
knowledge of what was happening in
Greece what was happening was that the
German invasion had driven out the Greek
King his immediate entourage and his
they all ended up in british-controlled
Egypt under British control but the king
left behind the bureaucracy and the
security forces of the former dictator
Yanis MEK taxes who under the king had
been the effective ruler of greece
Metaxas had tried to turn greece into a
nazi state complete with the greek
versions of the gestapo of the SS and
even Hitler Youth metaxas had died but
the regime he established lived on and
collaborated with the Germans indeed if
the Germans and the Italians had been
wise enough not to invade Greece but
taxes probably would have led his state
into the axis itself but like most
invaders the Germans were not was they
made the vast majority the Greeks their
enemies
seizing Greek industry and draining the
country of food they starved the
population finally desperate and angry
the Greeks developed a vigorous
political anti-nazi resistance movement
perhaps even more than Tito's partisans
movement the Greek National Liberation
Front the EAM grew into a national
movement the British Secret Intelligence
Service thought enroll virtually the
entire adult population and estimated
its military forces about 50,000
guerrilla fighters by comparison the
underground in France about which all of
us have heard much more the population
of six times as large probably never
loved numbered more than a tenth as many
and unlike the French underground the
EAM controlled
virtually the entire country like most
the Asian liberation movements it was
inspired by and partly led by the
Communists the a.m. was determined to
come out of the war heading for a new
way of life that movement terrified
Churchill he agreed with South Africa's
general Smuts that Greece was the first
domino to fall in what he called a wave
of disorder and wholesale communism it
was sweeping over Europe Greek
nationalists he decided were just
communists
different name not only would they not
block us so we had move south but they
would help the Soviets to sterilize both
the oil States to the Middle East and
the Western European states to block the
expected Russian move in the South was
he believed the imperative of just of
strategy so Churchill would as I fixed
firmly on Imperial strategy took an
initiative that shaped much of the world
of which we've lived during my lifetime
but it still is not fully appreciated so
let me recount just a bit of it the
surest way to regime change the iaea em
Churchill believed was military force
and the major military force was the one
General Eisenhower was readying for an
attack on German dominated Europe
Churchill tried very hard to get the
allied war prisoners to direct it from
Italy to Greece but eisenhower refused
rebuff
he decided on another strategy since he
thought that the Greek EAM was simply a
communist organization he concluded it
must be under the control of Stalin
so if Eisenhower wouldn't play ball the
game had to be played with Stalin in May
1944 Churchill sent Foreign Minister
Anthony Eden to Moscow to propose a deal
when the Russians seemed receptive
Churchill himself flew to Moscow in
October and sitting across the table
from Stalin in the Kremlin he scribbled
a short note which he passed over that
noticed today that in the public record
office in England in the note he
proposed the swap Britain would
recognize Soviet control over virtually
all of Eastern Europe if the Soviet
Union would recognize British control
over Greece Churchill snapped up the
offer so this from Churchill's deal that
the Soviet hegemony over Eastern Europe
may be dated and it happened almost a
year before the alter conference in
which our for which Roosevelt was
excoriated
having been self-taught on communism and
having been outsmarted by Stalin it was
the great chokehold war Churchill
himself who planted the cornerstone of
the Iron Curtain
the Iron Curtain was then hammered into
place by the Soviet Army's destruction
of the German army profiting from the
collapse of the German occupation of
Greece the British were then able to
invade Greece divided and weaken the
underground ever imposed the monarchy
keeping his part of the bargain Stalin
told the e/m leaders that they better
make a deal with the British the
Russians would not help them
the a.m tried to fight on and defeating
them proved to be expensive as Britain
was nearly broke it was no longer able
to afford Churchill's strategy so with a
remarkable sense of resilience in
rudeness Churchill turned to the
American Eagle knowing these events
helped us to understand both the
European Cold War and the American
intervention in Africa and Asia of
course America had no Indian empire to
protect and felt secure and holding on
to his share of Middle Eastern oil which
was mostly in what was essentially than
American dominated Saudi Arabia to win
its cooperation Britain had to sound a
different message that message was at
hand it was a combination of fear of
communism and the idea that nations were
like dominoes in essence that was the
message the Churchill took - is still
very unsophisticated Harry Truman
American leaders had feared communism
for decades and so convincing them of
the danger was easy and the Domino image
was visually dramatic it seemed both to
explain the war shattered European
states and the former colonial areas had
to point toward ways to secure them
above all it had the great virtue of
simplicity suddenly dominoes became
everyone's favorite game
it was eagerly played illegally attended
by all of Truman's closest advisors and
would become the image of American
policy in order
for decades to come even later when he
became President Ronald Reagan
proclaimed and I quote him that if the
Russians weren't engaged in this game of
dominoes there wouldn't be any hot spots
in the world so how to apply the Domino
image fear that the Warwick weakened
Italy in France would fall under
communist control was the challenge in
Europe while the Assumption the British
rule and Greece set the pattern for the
Truman Doctrine and the extension of the
American role in the Middle East and
South Asia meanwhile in the in the Far
East Japan had surrendered the American
government believed that more or less
single-handedly - won the Pacific War
and therefore was entitled to dictate
the peace it's so it sound a peace
treaty with Japan on its terms including
to the anger of the Russians the
preservation of the role of the Emperor
on an American battleship that under the
American flag without any Soviet
participation and established its own
administration both in Japan and that
part of Korea it controlled further it
massively but ultimately and effectively
supported the anti-communist Chinese
Ally Chiang kai-shek and aided France
also massively but equally and
effectively and its attempt to recapture
its indo-european colony taking a page
out of the British playbook for briefs
it said about suppressing the left-wing
America said about suppressing the
left-wing nationalist movement its
wartime Ally the Philippine underground
that seemed to American a sort of
oriental version of the am most
powerfully it also carried out the coup
d'etat that overthrew the democratic
elected government of Iran lurking
behind all these diverse and
little-understood movements was assumed
to be local Communists and Soviet
imperialism Truman and his advisors with
much encouragement thought that they had
to move massively into the chaos and
confusion of the post-war and
post-colonial world
if they did not they believed country
after country would tumble like dominoes
and America would find itself alone to
cope with this new world
President Truman concluded America would
have to reorganize itself part of the
model for the revamped government
already existed the task of mobilizing
deploying and sustaining a huge military
force as it had to do during World War
two gathering the necessary raw
materials organizing the industry to
fabricate weapons had forced the
creation of a vast new bureaucracy
recondite skills had to be improved or
acquired the American code breaking
effort for example in intelligence was
already well advanced and the extra
parts that had to be acquired could be
acquired from the British spying as was
polite because no call is called human
intelligence was avidly studied at the
feet of the British Secret Intelligence
Service by the OSS enough remained of
the pre-war Army and Navy to command a
command structure that it was able to
carry the weight of this vast new
expansion but Truman his advisers
thought that the early activities had to
be regularized and expanded thus in July
1947 at his urging Congress passed the
National Security Act the National
Security Act created both the National
Security Council the NSC and the
successor to the wartime intelligence
organization the CIA the innocent NSC
would preempt some of the traditional
functions of the cabinet under the
chairmanship of the President it was
shaped to favor a military view of
American overseas challenges as
originally organized it included the
civilian secretaries of defense Army and
Navy and Air Force but two years later
the civilian secretaries were grown were
dropped and were replaced by the general
who was the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff
as it evolved under President Eisenhower
or the NSC became a sort of executive
government within the traditional civil
government these were the first steps in
what came to be called the national
security state parallel to the NSC in
some ways to the CIA was another
organization the policy planning staff
when General George Marshall became
Secretary of State in 1947 he was
appalled to find that the civilian side
of the government had no general staff
so he created the policy planning staff
to lay out a master plan on how to deal
with the world at large and particularly
with the Soviet Union it was this task
that brought to the fore two
particularly remarkable mine George
Kennan and Paul netsy Kenan and it's his
views of the world and the task before
the American government were different
but they were different only in degree
both were hawks in the grand phrase and
both focused on the Soviet Union but can
believe that time was on the side of
America and that the Soviet Union would
evolve peacefully whereas miss he
thought the West had no time and he
advocated Swit action swift action
against an implacable an evil enemy as
Kenan summed up his position and I quote
the Soviet leadership had no
preconceived design for world conquest
his psychology was primarily defensive
but he also believed the Soviet Union
must face an impenetrable barrier that
barrier had to be a reconstructed Europe
anchored in Germany and this he under
wrote in the great program he initiated
the Marshall Plan that embodied the
concept of containment Kenan was no dove
indeed at that time there were
practically no doves roosting in the
White House or the State Department and
certainly not another defense department
Kenan not only favored the use of power
but he advocated using it in all of its
forms
including espionage however he saw to
rule out large-scale armed force which
would return the world he thought to
general war and so destroy its hopes for
well-being security and peace a wise
strategy he argued was together the USSR
time to evolve toward peace and
prosperity while at the same time
showing his leaders that aggressive
action did not work behind his analysis
there were some hard facts Russia had
been severely weakened by the German
invasion and had not recovered in 1947
the u.s. produced four times the amount
of steel five times the amount of
aluminum six times the amount of
kilowatt hours of power and eight times
the amount of oil as the Soviet Union
and the gap was widening in America's
favor carefully played out kenan thought
containment would forced the soviet
leaders to recognize that since the cost
of war was so horrible and the
advantages of america over the soviet
union were so great they would mellow
the time he argued was on the american
side that was not the conclusion of poll
let's see
netsy was kind of successor as director
of the policy planning staff and he set
out his argument and what was perhaps
the single most influential government
policy paper ever confirmed we know it
is NSC 68 NSC 68 which was commissioned
by President Truman on January 1 1950
called for a massive buildup of both
conventional and nuclear arms in the
deprecated cannons idea of containment
as he wrote without superior aggregate
military force and being and readily
mobilize able a policy of containment
which is an effective policy of
calculated the gradual coercion is no
more than a policy of bluff as McGeorge
Bundy commented when he delivered the
Henry Simpson lectures here fifteen
years ago NSC sixty-eight two
the gloomiest possible view of
containment indeed Nets his plan called
for America to prepare for war security
would be achieved by overwhelming
military force mrs. Atkins contrasting
physicians were never seriously debated
because on June 25 1950 North Korean
military forces crossed the 38th
parallel and invaded South Korea and in
a Secretary of State Dean Acheson
commented Korea preempted discussions on
American strategy the north korean
action was taken as confirmation of
midsi's argument it would become
American policy more immediately the
hard-fought nearly lost and nearly
nuclear Korean War contributed to a
climate of fear and mutual distrust so
evident Farm Affairs and in the decline
of mutual respect and civility within
American political circles these are
forces with which we continue to
struggle today then isn't it seized
position began to be known many of the
scientists who worked on the atomic bomb
were horrified as they saw unless these
nuclear weapons policy implemented of
what came to be called the
military-industrial complex
Einstein spoke for many of them when he
said if I'd known they were going to do
this I would have become a shoemaker he
and a number of other leading scientists
formed an organization to try to slow
down or even to give up nuclear weapons
but Nitz he had set out a worldview and
a plan that both Democrats and
Republicans found not only attractive
but necessary ironically NSC however
provoked a massive Soviet nuclear
weapons build-up itself and so it was in
effect
self-defeating as well as self
confirming the Soviet Union was and had
to be building up a potential for war
thirty years of difficult and dangerous
negotiations or relations followed and
during them Europe recover
but had become what came to be called a
what came to be called the Cold War
nearly exploded into nuclear war on
various occasions then the objective
that both Kenan and Nitz he had sought
came to fruition but not because of the
action either one of them had advocated
what happened were two developments that
neither cannon Arnott's he could have
predicted the first was that the Soviet
Union wrecked itself on the decade-long
campaign in the 1980s in the Afghan
mountains just as America had bogged
itself down in the 1960s and the
Vietnamese jungles the second
transformation was that when he became
the Soviet leader in the 1980s Mikhail
Gorbachev undertook a program of
divestiture of central control and
granting a virtual autonomy to the
Soviet republics in this process the
structure of the Soviet Union gave way
in the current phrase the Soviet Union
imploded
both Canada and netsy focused their
attention on the Soviet challenges in
Europe we can follow further closely how
they shaped the Cold War but there was
no comparable strategist on with the
French scholar Alfred
so V as Sony dubbed the tier Monde the
third world their countries of Africa
and Asia what came to be called the term
indoctrination of the British 19th
century policy aimed at protecting India
but the British called the forward
policy sought to block Russian moves
southward by creating a notional wall of
colonies or subservient regimes from the
Mediterranean to the Pacific starting in
in Egypt who Suez Canal formed another
sort of choke point like the Turkish
straits the British dominated the
Persian Gulf occupied Iran invaded
Afghanistan instead of outposts in
Central Asia organized a covert military
assistance program for China neutralized
Tibet and conquered Burma before
reaching the Anchorage of Singapore
the essence of that policy the notional
wall was picked up a century later by
john foster dulles when he became
Secretary of State he elaborate
elaborated by extensions of the European
wall of NATO into the Asian walls of
sento or the Baghdad pact for the Middle
East and Seto for the Southeast Asian
countries this was the essence of
American third-world strategy in the
1950s the question posed by Kenan etsion
Dulles was how to implement these
strategic notions the essential
questions were who would authorize them
who would pay for them and who would
implement them the inescapable Kanaan
durham is who makes the decisions the
president has staff Congress or the
American people as I've shown in my
second talk it was this essential
question that was argued by the
delegates to the Constitutional
Convention in 1787 and ruled upon by the
Supreme Court in 1936 it was approached
by different angles by American thinkers
during the Second World War
kenan and that's he agreed with each
other and with Alexander Hamilton that
the people were not qualified to make
decisions on vital issues of war and
peace but Madison and the delegates the
Constitutional Convention insisted and
that ignorant or not the people had to
be involved American thinkers
statesman's and educators had been
struggling with to bridge this dilemma
ever since the dilemma was succinctly
put by my favorite American humorist
Will Rogers he Lampoon us when he said
the problem ain't what the people know
it's what the people know that just
ain't so
the public lack of knowledge was
staggering the bitter commentator on
america ambrose bierce adapted the
English poet John Keats is line they
stood aloof and giant ignorance to
describe the American public one in four
Americans did not know the earth was
circles the Sun and despite the Mark
Twain's joke that God created war so
that Americans would learn geography
we're told that 88% of young Americans
couldn't find Afghanistan on the map
seventy-five percent couldn't locate
Iran or Israel sixty-three percent
couldn't find Iraq more than seven and
ten didn't know what the US government
said was the reason for the Cold War it
didn't get any better among the elite
among the financially most successful
private citizens wealthy donors two
successful presidential candidates who
were being nominated to represent the
United States abroad if you had even a
vague notion of the country to to which
they were being assigned sometimes they
didn't even know where the country was I
didn't intended to speak of the attempts
to upgrade the knowledge of the public
through education but because of the
time constraints I had to drop that part
of my analysis I've written about it
elsewhere I also as a teacher have to
admit that the effort has been while the
effort has been impressive it is not
resulted in a sophisticated America as
governor Wallace governor Morris of New
York a delegate to the ID 1787
congressional conference remarked one
objective of the Constitution was to
save the people from their most
dangerous enemy themselves the founding
fathers were deeply concerned about the
manipulation of the fickle and ignorant
public by tyrants and they sought to
guard the Republic structurally and
defensively they were not willing to
adopt Hamilton's reshaping of America
into an aristocracy but thought they
could accomplish the same name by
dividing the decision-making process and
by
centering the decision to go to war and
the branch of government most
immediately responsive to the public the
Congress but in the early days that
Congress was just the public with all
this faults and shortcomings the faults
and shortcomings were glaringly at our
glaringly evident today Congress makes
little attempt to embody the national
interest but is itself essentially up
for sale or rent as the members assemble
the money they think they need to be
reelected few of them served in
government who of us who served in
government have much respect or for
either its wisdom or its integrity what
the Founding Fathers sought was
overturned in the centralization of
war-making powers in the hands of the
president as we've seen as a consequence
of the Cold War and is shaped by other
parts of the world by the extension of
the Truman Doctrine has spilled out an
NSC 68 and subsequent acts the president
gun on his own authority launched Wars
and even a worldwide general war with or
without provocation in turn or in some
our lives are completely and utterly in
his hands this is true even if he
happens to be suffering from a headache
has slept badly as exhausted has a
temper tantrum or is even drunk as I
have learned personally during the Cuban
Missile Crisis and the heat of such
crisis when one is exhausted one's
judgment is always fragile and if one is
also suffering from numerous other
problems the fragility becomes a mortal
threat to all of us as the Defense
Secretary Robert McNamara has written I
quote him the whole situation seemed so
bizarre as to be beyond belief on any
given day as we go about our business
the president is prepared to make a
decision within 20 minutes it could
launch the most devastating weapons of
the world that is what we've lived with
for 40 years and with few changes this
system remains
in tact we have so far been lucky but
lucky is not a stable base for policy we
can always count on having leaders of
good sense and good will nor of course
can we count on others also having them
as our wise old philosopher Ben Franklin
commented at the Constitutional
Convention he trusted the first
president George Washington but he was
not sure he would be able to trust any
of his successors as yet it is come into
focus in our times
Washington's successors have the sole
control of the life of death of all of
us I turn now to what could provoke the
operation of presidential power and the
flow of ambiguous often provocative and
dangerous events long before the phrase
was spoken the Soviet Union was
considered the evil empire what we saw
in our magic mirror as I've spelled out
in my first talk was that we were decent
honorable and peace-loving as John
Winthrop had told us we were doing what
we did standing on the top of ära Hill
for the benefit of the world virtually
everyone in the US government assumed
the worst of the Soviet Union so finding
out what the Russians were doing was it
was already in 1946 so urgent as to
create what was called in government
circles I need to know already in 1946
the Air Force had begun monitoring the
borders of the Soviet Union and it's
satellites as implicit American and
Soviet gentlemen's agreement came into
force the both sides were fairly
restricted in the way they approached
this task so we had planes flew along
the Atlantic coast of America and
American planes flew along the frontiers
of the Soviet Union and at first another
side tried to shoot down the other or to
invade its territory then in 1949 the
Soviet Union exploded its first nuclear
device
and November 1950 Chinese forces entered
Korea and on December 16 1960 1950
President Truman declared a state of
national emergency
suddenly gathering intelligence on the
Soviet Union its capabilities
particularly on the assumed - presumed
ability the Soviet Air Force to attack
America across Alaska and Canada became
insistent Truman immediately approved
aerial penetrations of Siberia the US
had just acquired a new relatively fast
high-flying bomber the b-47 it could be
modified for the task the pilots of the
b-47 took the first step in what became
a lengthy game in which American and
Russian fighter planes intercepted
followed photographed etc but did not
normally try to shoot down the other
Saudi aircraft however surveillance soon
turned into provocation and the spring
of 1956 President Eisenhower authorized
a major aerial invasion of the Soviet
Union armed b-47 bombers took off on
american air base and through greenland
and overthrew verse read the whole
stretch of the Soviet Arctic as James
Benford has written I quote him over
seven weeks almost daily between eight
and ten bombers launched refueled over
the North Pole and continued south over
the Russian border in one incursion six
armed aircraft flying abreast flaunted
American power and broad daylight as
though on a nuclear bombing run had they
not been caught unprepared the Russians
might well have launched a
counter-attack with devastating results
the Soviet military came to regard
penetrations of its airspace is
intolerable
it was after all on the front to their
professionalism the first armed clash
came apparently in 1949 and in the
following eleven years a dozen or more
US aircraft were shot down or Christ
enter near the Soviet Union another site
admitted their existence
finally the CIA ordered a new aircraft
the Lockheed jet powered glider the u2
and had it flown by CIA pilots it was
the CIA contract pilot Gary Powers who
flew the u2 that brought down was
brought down over the USSR in May 1960
the shooting down of the u2 was perhaps
the most publicized event of the Cold
War I have to interject here a small
personal anecdote some years later I was
invited to lecture at the Soviet Academy
of Sciences and I was being met at the
airport bump my old friend you get any
promote calls who later became the
Soviet prime minister and was then the
fellow of the Institute of which I was
president and when he met me at the
airport he said congratulations
I had no visa to go to Russia
congratulations you are the first
American to come to Russia without a
visa since garriepowers
fortunately the advances in rocket
technology have now largely rendered
obsolete which could have been a trigger
for war but of course many others
resulted from the very advance of
technology there now many more pieces of
highly dangerous Hardware placed in
exposed regions are being used as props
and signaling what strategists say is
intent or warning thus almost as
dangerous as provocations were accidents
and mistakes as we all know from our
daily lives when almost anything even
paper clips run into the thousands some
are almost certain to get lost dropped
or broken so it's been with nuclear
weapons despite great and expensive
efforts that command and control there
have been a number of near catastrophes
and presumably the Russians have had
similar experiences it's believed that
about 50 bombs have been lost at sea
along with 26 nuclear reactors from 1950
to 1980 what happened after that date is
so far on
recorded but it probably as many as a
thousand significant nuclear bomb
accidents any one of which could have
just wiped out a large city have
occurred former Secretary of Defense
William Perry reported one that shows
how monitor could be the start of the
nuclear war the watch officer at the
Strategic Air Command called him up in
the middle of the night one time when he
was Deputy Secretary of Defense to
report the 200 ICBMs had been picked up
on radar heading for America from Russia
fortunately the general quickly found
out that the wrong tape had been
inserted in the computer it was a near
miss a response by American aircraft
could have been a real-life enactment of
the movie dr. Strangelove sometimes even
more dangerous than deliberate
provocation was accident or or accident
was routine during the week of the Cuban
Missile Crisis the American Air Force
went ahead with the previously scheduled
test of an ICBM it was programmed after
all and all the arrangements had been
made so despite the fact that we were
hovering on the brink of a war those in
charge simply went ahead what I well I
had access to all the actions during
that week I did not find out about the
missile test until later remarkably the
Soviet intelligences her favorite
services didn't seem to find it either
had they done so they presumably would
have regarded as directed against their
forces in Cuba with also possibly the
beginning of a World War one does not
have to be a paranoid or believer in
conspiracy theories to question whether
such near misses or accidental or
deliberate I had some reason to know
that a number of our senior military and
some senior civilian officials were
pushing the president very hard toward
war during the Missile Crisis the
Russians detected the firing of that
particular missile and reacted the
president almost certainly would have
been forced to adopt what the generals
were
trying to force him to do mr. Perry who
was closer to the military than I
reached the same conclusion as he wrote
many wanted to rush us into war one plan
to rush us into war was called Operation
Northwoods it was a complex violent and
indeed treasonous plan to provoke a war
with Cuba both real and simulated
attacks on Americans in which some would
be murdered and the public would be told
they had been killed by order of Castro
almost certainly the president would
have been pushed into war had had plan
been carried out the plan was prepared
by a secret military unit under the
auspices of the then chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff General Lyman
Lemon sir
lemon sir also attempted to enlist his
fellow generals so the plan could have
been in the opening gun of a coup d'etat
in effect the coup had really already
begun as the military commander was
making plans and creating situations
which it would not reveal to the
civilian superiors including the
Secretary of Defense the Joint Chiefs of
Staff prevented even the Secretary of
Defense finding out about their
activities but rather foolishly they
revealed at least part of their plans to
the think tank they'd set up the RAND
Corporation and they're one of the
political military technicians their
additions Daniel Ellsberg recalled and
horror from their plan and then just
booked last year the doomsday machine he
pointed out that if it had been
implemented the planned nuclear strikes
would have wiped out every city and most
towns of the Soviet Union and China
killing about half the world's
population devastating most of the rest
of the world and almost certainly would
have caused a Soviet counter-attack that
even with the small remnant of the
Soviet forces that had survived would
have killed about half the American
population as Ellsberg learned the air
force chief general Curtis LeMay tried
to keep the authority and ability to
order
on his own I had reason to believe that
ellisburg assessment of Lemay's desire
to strike the Soviet Union was correct
during my time on the policy planning
council I was sent to ask for me about
the message he'd been leaking to his
friends in the Congress that the Chinese
development nuclear weapons must be
stopped and that the Air Force could do
the job the parallel to North Korea
today I'm sure will strike all of you an
answer to my questions for detailed on
what he proposed to Kennedy's critics
but may said laid out a plan for an
attack that certainly would have
precipitated world war 3 he was planning
to apply 70 bombers across China toward
the Soviet Union to devastate the area
out and sink yon province where the
Chinese were making and testing their
nuclear weapon development program as
you will have observed I had to leave
out many topics in the time we've spent
together I've concentrated on the larger
sense of strategy than the flow of
events I've touched on here but I've
written about most of them elsewhere the
challenges in our society that were
brought about by the growth of the
military-industrial complex and the
lamentable and dangerous decline in the
standards of civil discussion of
national affairs
perhaps I can do no better than to leave
you with the plea as each of us view
reviews the doleful events the daily
impaired impinge on our thoughts we go
to the bottom line do we feel safer as a
result of the policies we've implemented
or not if not then what could we have
learned
I'm impressed with two sequences of
events time proved to work in the Cold
War we are further from war with the
Soviet Union today than we once were and
once we got off of Vietnam it was
fascinating how dramatic and how rapid
the process of healing was in that
country
and our relations with it but we've not
applied these successes to other cases
and we've gone back indeed now to the
failed policy to the 1950s in pushing
NATO for example into the Russian
security zone in the Ukraine and in
seeking to overwhelm with the regime
change local societies by force or by
threat of force in the third world and
sometimes by the assassination of
leaders of other nations as the Senate
committee under Senator Frank church was
able to document one in one instance of
President Nasser was under attack and he
told senator George McGovern that there
had been 25 serious attempts to
assassinate him
McGovern came back and demanded that the
CIA telling what the facts from their
point of view were and they came back
and said of the 25 he mentioned we were
only responsible for 12
but we've applied we've not applied our
successes and have not gone back to find
out what caused our failures indeed we
are going back to the failed policies in
the 1950s we have reacted horribly
horror at the action of those we call
terrorists and who call themselves
defenders there is much savage savagery
on both sides and the terrible events
that arises from this clash I'm not
qualified to pass a moral judgement but
I'm trying to evaluate results our
attempt to achieve security military
power military version murder and other
means have not worked nor are they
likely to do so worse as the effects
spread the virtual certainty of blowback
on our society even in the very attempt
to achieve Graduate Society will also
grow it is long past time for us to
reconsider I think what we're doing now
how the world is changing and what we
need to change to go with it the
for security must not bind us as a great
teacher as I quoted earlier Benjamin
Franklin warned those who would give up
The Essential Liberty to purchase a
little temporary safety deserve neither
liberty nor safety thank you very much
[Applause]
we have time ladies and gentlemen
professor Pope well you kind of yes sir
yes sir
yes sir to assures stress I didn't catch
the first part what what I specifically
was concerned with is we have seen when
we trained for example in the Navy SEAL
organization people who as a matter of
routine are trained to kill people and
we ran into the same thing in Vietnam
one of my colleagues in Washington was a
very civilized sophisticated and able
man by the name of Bob comer he and I
were two of the three members of the
crisis management committee during the
Cuban Missile Crisis and I had an
enormous respect for his decency his
intelligence and everything else
suddenly I found that when he went out
to Vietnam he helped to create and was
in charge of a program called Phoenix
and the Phoenix program murdered
something like 20,000 Vietnamese many of
whom were in effect in quotes sold by
their local enemies or people to whom
they owed money and or who did not pay
them protection money so that this
program was involved a fairly large
number of Americans in the act
that's not very dissimilar to the the
Mafia activities and in effect we were
creating a category of people with an
experience of violating our code
of decency and law and order and those
people then coming back into American
society or it seems to me a very serious
danger yes ma'am can you speak up just
for short
basically empowering women giving women
worldwide more equity more money even as
a means of achieving international
security is that something that's
compelling for your do you think it's
just sort of a product of our times and
what do you think about the State
Department sort of moving away from that
I would say in the past couple of years
where as several years prior so we saw
more money going towards
let me see if I fully understand whether
women would play a more beneficial role
in peace seeking than men I have been
fortunate in my life to know a large
number of women some of them were very
nice some of them are not nice that's
also true of men I think the division of
men versus women is is a false one I
think we're talking about good people
versus bad people whether the men are
women and for example at mrs. Mayer's
request I negotiated the peace treaty
between or the ceasefire between Egypt
and Israel mrs. Mayer was a very very
tough woman I don't think she was any
lover of peace at all the the thing that
she was involved with was a certain
number of the Israeli citizens were
being shot and bombed on the Suez Canal
and she wanted to stop that on the other
hand mrs. mrs. miracle is I think a
major force for peace in the world
today so I think there I think it's it
isn't if you pardon my saying so I think
it's a sort of an American jump into
conclusion to say women versus men I
think it's like saying white people
versus black people of known wonderful
black people and I've known a lot of
awfully bad white people and but to make
that distinction I think is a false one
I think empowerment of everybody
men or women is a very significant goal
that we all ought to move for we need to
have a world in which we first of all
respect other people and secondly we
listen to them and we don't really do
either one of those
today and I think we paid a terrible
price for that how you had a second
point I think there is an issue about
essential qualities in peace loving for
both men and women we all have stomachs
and as long as we have a large part of
the world population that goes hungry to
bed every night people don't have as
much need or our desire for peace as
people who are relatively better off
that is an important thing but I have
found in my study of history that people
are very often willing to give up even
their jobs and even their homes provided
you don't attack their sense of dignity
and that is in a sense the the persona
issue is it seems to me so enormous
importance we've we've recognized that
in our approach to dealing with the
Jewish population the survivors of the
Holocaust where we've apologized but we
have we collectively in the West have
killed an awful lot of people in the
world and have destroyed a great deal of
other cultures and other societies and
it seems to me that one of the things
that a radical solution or not solution
but a radical contribution to toward a
solution about the world would be to
wage the the sense of outrage that
people have the the Army for example
conducted a study in Afghanistan not
very long ago in which they found that
the level of violence was inversely
proportion to the activities the
American military command the the
stronger the actions of the Americans
against in quote terrorists were the
more violent activity
that particular area experienced to the
degree that we can find ways that that
where we don't affront people in the
world even if we don't feed them it
seems to me it would be a major step
forward but of course we need to also
think about the disparity of income the
disparity of Hope that people have I
when I was young I spent a fair amount
of time in both Africa and Asia and I
found that one of the remarkable things
was that when you came across people who
had that sense of cohesion and integrity
or cohesion and self-respect they were
perfectly willing to give up
particularly to entertain a foreign
guest but it was an enormous ly
expensive to them you think of a poor
better one in the in the desert who is
willing to slaughter virtually his last
sheep in order to entertain a guest
would be comparable in comparable terms
like my being willing to give a guest my
house and you know that was virtually
his life but the integrity the sense of
decency the sense of honor was more
strong even than the material issue and
to the degree that we can change our
attitude toward the sense of seriousness
and decency and honesty of other people
that's a real move toward peace whether
it's men or women is to me irrelevant
yes sir
one of the hallmarks of credible if
their strategy dating back of course so
many decades is the ability of the
executive to essentially kind of quickly
launch based on flexible set of options
like the ones that Thomas set out for
the US president I'm wondering kind of
based on your comments what you think in
the post-cold war era about
strengthening checks on presidential
launch authority of nuclear weapons and
what that might mean for the credibility
of us extended deterrence UN's
deterrence in general well the United
States faces potential adversaries I
think your question is a very important
one did all of you hear that - yeah
I'm partially deaf so I'm sensitive to
whether people hear anything and I think
that a part of the problem lies beyond
your question part of the problem is
that events leading up to that question
are have to be stopped at an earlier
stage an analogy that I've came to in my
government service was if you think of
policies or actions of any one of us but
particularly a government like an
alphabet you take step a and you take
accept B you take step C it's almost
inevitable that you have you take step D
because it's the logical consequence
when you've taken steps a B and C to
then try to the change and go over to a
different alphabet it's very hard to do
and it doesn't usually work but the
problem that you raise is a very
difficult one in the case of the Cuban
Missile Crisis where I happened to have
sort of cut my teeth on this this this
question the president was certainly
prepared to react but in the
Constitution the president is not
supposed to react proactively
he's not supposed to carry out a first
strike and what really fighting the
Russians in the Cuban Missile Crisis and
almost led to the war and certainly led
to the crisis itself was the fact that
we were stationing nuclear weapons in
Izmir that were first strike weapons
they were liquid fired weapons the
Russians weren't worried about the
Bombers we had in central Anatolia they
were very worried about the missiles and
they countered that with their missiles
in Cuba and the swap was to get rid of
both of them the swap was a very
intelligent thing but it was extremely
hard for President Kennedy to do because
he was he was a quote a liberal who was
elected on a very thin margin of votes
and he was he felt very delicate about
that and the military was pushing him
very hard to engage in war and war is is
a curious thing too in terms of judging
from what you you commented but the
Thursday of the missile crisis all of us
were so exhausted but I don't think
anybody he's certainly not I had any
sense that we were really thoroughly in
control of our emotions and at a certain
point the feeling was let's just get it
all over with and I think that's a very
dangerous situation so to the degree
possible one needs to a avoid the issue
and so far as you could possibly do it
before that question before the question
you raised comes up and B when you if
you've not been able to do it then it
seems to me that you still the the best
hope you have is to not have the
immediate reaction if you have a
virtually automatic reaction as we all
saw in dr. Strangelove for example then
all hope is gone and in fact much of the
technology that we've developed about
the control of nuclear weapons depends
on virtual automatic reaction so with
this is a very delicate and complicated
question but within a general
perspective I would be in favor of
preventing the president from having
that kind of control and as we've seen
in this Benjamin Franklin warned us
about what we were likely to face in
American politics we have to recommend
we won't always have a president who is
extremely stable and is extremely able
to control the forces of his own mind
much less the society sir yeah could I
just follow up on that a little I'm
sorry my voice is not what it should be
by coming back to something I mentioned
yeah an evening but not in front of the
group
this is is following on my understanding
is that in the last year of the Nixon
administration when he had become quite
paranoid and was getting drunk a lot and
giving bizarre orders at night this is
Nixon Nixon yeah yeah a set of protocols
was give up whereby he was he was told
yes this will be done mr. president we
go back to bed and so forth and that it
was actually even formalized into or
semi in formalized into an agreement
among the Joint Chiefs that if ordered
to launch any and the first strike
against the Soviet Union they wouldn't
do it unless all five of them agreed
even though this was in violation of the
chain of command and I sort of so I
think that maybe it's to pollyannaish of
me I suspect that there's some sort of
informal agreements around Trump as well
and so to my mind
but this isn't my question isn't it
isn't the real danger not that he would
that we would inadvertently or through
some executive overreach started World
War three
with the Russians or with the Chinese
isn't the danger much more the kind of
war that the military wouldn't mind
having much less like Iran let's say I'm
getting a you know ramping up the
conflict with Iran and so it's it's not
these reading these Armageddon type
scenarios we really have to fear because
after all these generals they themselves
have families and children and
grandchildren and they don't want to
blow up the world necessarily but it
does seem to me that the real the real
threat is much more these kind of
medium-size powers or I mean Iran is the
most obvious one right now I'm scared to
death of both of them but I think that
the I think you're right there would be
more likelihood of the military going
along with the idea of attacking Iran
for example and that's what they did in
Iraq but Nixon was a very strange man in
many many ways I was asked to by Henry
Kissinger to join his his government and
I said to Kissinger who was then working
for Rockefeller that if Rockefeller were
elected I would be willing to talk about
the job they offered me but with Nixon I
certainly wouldn't and I think probably
the military felt a little bit that way
too
but the whole theory of deterrence rests
on the idea that it would be absolutely
automatic that regardless of anything
else the military had to go along with
this and that the the Soviet Union had
to know that the military would not be
able to stop it so I think the the issue
is to some extent academic that whether
indeed it would happen one way or the
yes sir
are there any easy questions I think we
know all of us are terribly failed and
all of our capacity terribly flawed in
our capacity to deal with any of these
questions there was never an intent that
I know of that anybody thought that the
UN would be really an executive
organization and we in the American
government treated it was utter contempt
unless we wanted to use it for some
reason and the idea that a group of
people sitting in the Security Council
could really perform the task that we
would like to perform is very slight and
they had no capacity of course to
allocate military force or to do other
things and in fact from the Russian
point of view the Security Council has
been essentially an American operation
and the whole UN has been an American
operation but my hunch is that you have
a better chance with an ecumenical group
of people of a group of people from
various different countries that was as
a point of Dobbin and one of my earlier
talk that was the intent behind the
American emphasis on using the Congress
rather than the President to make these
basic decisions because the Congress was
presumed to be close to the people and a
Security Council could be presumed to be
closer to world
than the opinion of anyone government
but I think the actual implementation of
that is to be desired
their arguments despite 20 years forever
war most people I wonder if if maybe
there are domains in which negative has
been successful at well I think that's a
very very important point a very
important issue to determine my own
personal experience has been that as I
think I mentioned earlier on that when I
was a young man I traveled around quite
supposedly disturbed areas
I felt perfectly safe today I don't I
couldn't go into most of those areas I
was in Afghanistan again for the
umpteenth time two years ago and I
stayed with the American ambassador and
I was checked in five times through
various groups of mercenaries that were
hired to protect the ambassador and the
embassy and could not move outside the
embassy
at all whereas in 1962 I took a 2,000
mile trip around Afghanistan and went to
every village and talked to everyone I
could possibly talk to I was in Libya
with similar experiences in Somalia on
and on and on I feel relatively safe I
must say here but two things worry me
about the future that that make make it
difficult to produce your report card
right now we haven't had the final exam
one of these is as I mentioned people
coming back into American society from
extremely violent experience and long
term violent experience not just one
time but a lot of times and if you look
at the statistics of the Veterans
Administration hospitals you find the
post traumatic experience impact has
been enormous ly powerful on a very
large number of people indeed so many
that I would doubt that many of them
even had very much combat experience but
the ones with severe combat experience
of the statistics on spousal abuse on
robbery on violence on murder on on
nervous breakdown on suicide the whole
range of things have been enormously
powerful and those are people who are
now coming back into our society there
are uncles cousins husbands and so forth
with large numbers of people what kind
of an impact do they have on our sense
of of civility I don't know the number
of handguns in America as we all know
the number of people who feel under the
threat of violence not violence but
under the threat of violence
as enormous Lee increased and I think
the weather however one feels about the
right or wrong or most of the issues we
were talking about if you've talked to
people who've lost a brother or lost a
cousin or lost a child in a bombing raid
you find a great deal of understandable
anger and the more we use drones and
other things and carry out a midnight
raids and kill people it seems to me
that we would have to be very naive to
think that at some point these people
are not going to react and blow back as
the expression is into our way of life
our society the horrible thing that we
all have focused on for the last decade
or so has been of course the the attack
on the World Trade Center but there are
a lot of things before the World Trade
Center that make it not don't justify it
but make it understandable and the
difference between justification and
understanding is I think often blurred
that we need to understand a lot of
things that we don't understand about
what causes people to do things so my I
feel quite pessimistic about the future
in those terms I think that the number
of likely attacks on civilian targets is
is is very much enhanced and if I were
policy planner for a violent group I
would say you're doing it just right the
trick is to make you feel unable to do
certain things that you like to do that
was that spelled out I think I mentioned
this in another context and another
lecture
the real architect of the theory of
counterinsurgency was a British officer
by the name of Caldwell he wrote a book
called small wars and his idea was that
the way you have to beat down colonial
people
is to hit them where it really hurts
them the things that things they really
count about and this is I don't know
whether any of these leaders of the
various insurgencies have read them but
this it seems to me use is the essence
of the smart policy for them but they
need to do is to cause us to do things
like jiu-jitsu where we use our own
strengths against ourselves and look at
what the result was of the 9/11 attack
in New York for cost of maybe a hundred
thousand dollars and the lives of
perhaps 15 or so they're willing agents
Osama bin Laden cause America to spend
two or three billion dollars or maybe
more in in all kinds of new measures
causes it to put surveillance units
around the country cause us to mobilize
the militia forces cost us tremendous
amounts of money in various other ways
and Kiedis into a position where we lost
a lot of our freedom and that was a
pretty smart move it was one of it was I
think you have to admit perhaps the most
successful military campaign ever
carried out but practically nothing they
won a very considerable victory and I
think that they're not stupid whatever
else you may think about them and the
the smart thing to do is to do similar
things so I expected no matter how much
survived wants to use how much control
we have over surveillance of our bodies
of our cities and everything else there
will probably be other attacks and the
military campaign in Syria resulted in a
loss of territory
by the Islamic state but the people who
were not killed went home and the
Russians tell me that they're very much
more worried about the people who went
home than there are about the people who
stayed and are trying to do things in
Middle East and I think that what you
will have to to anticipate is the next
generation will look back at those
people as the heroes of the older
generation that fought the good fight
and they will they will be the people
who will set the tone just as we believe
the people who fought the Russians
fought the British and the American
Revolution for our heroes and we have
trotted empty follow them as much as we
can that's not a very good analogy I
admit but but I think the the essence is
that we're at the beginning of a process
not at the end not just one but there
are three steps
[Applause]
[Music]